laser als kriegswaffen ähnlich wie in
star wars filme und das us militär
entwickelt tatsächlich kampfflugzeuge
die mit einem laser system ausgestattet
sind das soll dann ihre piloten im
ernstfall von drohnen und raketen
schützen sehkraft die ersten tests in
der luft sollen schon in vier jahren
stattfinden
wie das technisch funktionieren soll und
vor welchen konsequenzen jetzt kritiker
waren das jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
directed energy also zielgerichtet der
energie so werden laserwaffen im
militärischen sprachgebrauch genannt
laser sind mittlerweile tatsächlich
technisch soweit weiterentwickelt dass
das militär große hoffnung in sie setzt
jetzt hat die amerikanische
rüstungsfirma loket martin bekannt
gegeben dass an einem ganz konkreten
lasersystem geforscht wird und zwar im
auftrag der us airforce genaugenommen
seiner forschungsabteilung dem airforce
research lab frl
nach angaben der rüstungsfirma soll die
us airforce dafür 26,3 millionen us
dollar also umgerechnet 22,6 millionen
euro locker gemacht haben der konkrete
auftrag die entwicklung eines
lasersystems für flugzeuge
das bereits in vier jahren in der praxis
getestet werden könnte das projekt heißt
lance und das steht für laser at once
menz von next generation compact
environments übersetzt also in etwa
leser entwicklung für kompakte
einsatzmittel der nächsten generation
und jetzt ein mögliches szenario
der kampfjet pilot plötzlich eine
flugabwehrrakete die auf ihn zu gast die
erste reaktion ganz klar ausweichen
doch die rakete explodiert die bedrohung
ist ausgeschaltet denn der pilot hat
einen laserstrahl abgefeuert von einer
kanone an bord seines kampfjets das wäre
dann also demnächst tatsächlich möglich
offiziell so heißt es von seiten der
rüstungsfirma sollen die leser waffen
zur selbstverteidigung beitragen der us
rüstungskonzern hatte bereits in den
vergangenen jahren so laserwaffen
geforscht 2014 hatten sie mit einem 10
kilowatt faserlaser ein schlauchboot
versenkt und zwar auf einer entfernung
von etwa 1,6 kilometern in einem versuch
vor zwei jahren zerstört die die energie
eines lesers die motorhaube eines
kleinlasters jetzt sollen die leser so
klein und leicht werden dass sie eben
auch an kampfflugzeugen befestigt werden
können einen 60 kilowatt laser der auf
ein fahrzeug montiert werden kann wurde
bereits in diesem jahr an die us armee
ausgeliefert einer der verantwortlichen
von lockheed martin rupp afzal
bezeichnet den plan ein leser
waffensystem auf einem flugzeug zu
installieren als eine völlig neue und
andere herausforderung und weiter die
entwicklung von hochleistungs
lasersystemen zeigt
das laser waffensysteme real werden die
technik ist so weit dass sie gebaut
getestet und in flugzeugen fahrzeugen
oder auf schiffen eingesetzt werden kann
dass es überhaupt so weit kommen kann
und leser auch für das militär höchst
interessant sind liegt an ihrer
technischen weiterentwicklung für
kampfjets geplant sind sogenannte
faserlaser also festkörperlaser die aus
einer glasfaser bestehen und eine metall
der seltenen erden wie neodym oder
erbium die laserstrahlung wird verstärkt
durch die länge der faser diese kann
allerdings aufgewickelt werden so dass
sie nicht viel platz wegnimmt für im
betrieb braucht es strom der laut
militär forschungsteams ganz leicht
durch batterien bereitgestellt werden
kann
ältere leser brauchen einen gas oder ein
kristall als medium
dadurch werden die lichtwellen verstärkt
zudem gibt es eine genau justierte optik
aus spiegeln und ihr könnt es euch
vorstellen das ist viel zu anfällig um
es beispielsweise in flugzeugen
einzusetzen
durch die neue technik ist das us
rüstungsunternehmen optimistisch schon
bald erste tests mit laserwaffen in der
luft zu machen 2021 soll das der fall
sein es gibt allerdings auch experten
und expertinnen die da skeptischer sind
der us-kongress beispielsweise schreibt
in einem bericht von diesem herbst dass
es bereits noch viele technische aspekte
gibt die in sachen laserwaffen noch
nicht ausgereift seien auch die
us-marine und das
us-verteidigungsministerium forschen zu
laserwaffen die forschungsagentur des
us-verteidigungsministeriums plant ein
system mit einem elektrischen leser mit
dem von flugzeugen aus bodenziele
bekämpft werden sollen klingt alles
irgendwie nach star wars aber bei all
diesen plänen darf die ungeheure macht
der strahlen waffen nicht unterschätzt
werden nicht umsonst ist der einsatz von
anti personen lesern international
geächtet und zwar in einer un konvention
das völkerrechtliche rahmenabkommen der
vereinten nationen heißt sie dabei das
ist die abkürzung für convention und
politischen restrictions on the use of
certain conventional weapons 1998 trat
das vierte protokoll in kraft das den
einsatz blind machen da laserwaffen
verbietet die betonung liegt auf einsatz
denn die entwicklung und lagerung
solcher waffen sind von dem verbot
ausgenommen auch die federation of
american scientists
in der sich zahlreiche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
organisiert haben
die hat eine warnung vor laserwaffen
ausgesprochen denn soldaten können beim
einsatz sehr leicht erblinden ja wenn er
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
klicken die erste leser waffe der welt
auf schiffen können leser nämlich schon
eingesetzt werden und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran